every other day they set off at dawn to
scour the surrounding mountains
volunteer Rangers from nearby villages
under hunt for poachers I used to be a
lot of poachers
that's why the number of animals was
decreasing will most didn't see any in
the mountains anymore
we noticed that and it was scary so we
started to work so now we're protecting
42,000 acres the mountains of Kyrgyzstan
are home to some of the richest variety
of wildlife in the world including boars
deer and ibex and the much elusive Snow
Leopard which lives on the peaks the
Kyrgyz call it the spirit of the
mountains an animal sought-after for its
fur meat and bones used in traditional
medicine coluche cow was save as a cub
her mother's paw was caught in a trap
she was brought to the naboo century one
of the largest for these wild cats in
the world and remains here since more
than half of the territory of kyrgyzstan
is potential home to snow leopards they
live and protect the mountains of
Central Asia the tension here the
premiere in Tajikistan and the Himalayas
they are all interconnected and those
mountains provide water for nearly half
of the world's population to understand
more of these animals conservationists
are using modern technology about 40
heat and movement triggered cameras are
placed on top of the mountains for six
months at a time
they cover an area of 900,000 square
kilometers the thousands of pictures
taken reveal a lot about these animals
daily habits this one with the tail up
is marking the rock it's hard to use
binoculars and find them you will find
maybe their pug marks on the snow but
but without technologies you can't work
on small parts the snaps and videos also
help estimate the number of snow
leopards living in an area each cat has
a unique pattern on its fur similar to
fingerprints for humans there are at
least 350 living on the peaks there
probably more which is a significant
improvement since the 1990s when
poaching was rife that's why new Rodina
yev wants a poacher himself says it's
important to keep on patrolling the
mountains now we see deers and other
wild animals again villagers joke with
us and tell us to stop it because the
wild animals are eating their crops or
the poachers tell us you used to be one
of us why did you change sides
but it's good now tourists can come here
and see the animals it's a fragile
ecosystem the survival of one animal
depends on the survival of others and in
this impoverished country wildlife
protection has also become a source of
income but dr. Hameed al jazeera
kyrgyzstan